c'est dommage parce que vous avez été
tellement bon ce soir qu'est ce que que
ça m'ennuie de faire ce que je vais
faire maintenant
alors des genres à introduire la
revanche un logement prend tous les
vendredis avec lui le landi aussi
maintenant c'est tout le temps qui
promet wein et compagnie alors on va
démarrer la rubrique par une petite
photo déjà pour de mettre en condition
voilà joyeux anniversaire bertrand ça si
vous voulez vous en dire deux mots
simplement voilà c'est pour arrondir mes
fins noir c'est ce qu'on peut vous
n'aimez pas mais vine vous qui en faites
tant mon cher battant et je me suis
amusé ça m'a pris mon fils m'a beaucoup
aidé on a été chercher tous les vannes
et nous allons les trouver dans the
revenge maintenant
[Applaudissements]
dites moi maintenant ce que vous pensez
de celui ci on ne savait pas que
bertrand avait des talents de chanteur
je me veux tu en voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]